Peace be upon you
[applause]
[music]
And I and I accepted the marriage I accepted the marriage to her
It is for myself, for myself, according to the book of God, according to the book of God, and the Sunnah of His Messenger,
and the Sunnah of His Messenger, may God bless him and grant him peace, may God bless him and grant him peace, and on the
dowry and on the
dowry named, among the named among us, Mubarak
[applause] [
applause  ] [
Music]
[Applause]
[Music] [
Applause] [
Music]
[Music]
I would like to say that I am very happy that I have come to the wedding of the
Crown Prince in the age period
I am in so that I can live the full atmosphere
and feel very proud and happy. This wedding is the
wedding of the Jordanians.  They are all at the wedding of the youth,
all of Jordan is happy, joy spreads throughout
Jordan, the streets of Jordan, the governorates of Jordan, the youth of
Jordan from different governorates are present
[applause]
[music]